do you know why I pulled you over
because you think I'm cute and you want
to take me to a Red Lobster talk to me
about this show loosely exactly Nicole
how did this even come up MTV pitched me
a show that was different than this one
we shot the pilot and then they're like
you know what we think your life is very
interesting so why don't we base the
show around your weird little life and I
was like okay if it's great I would say
each episode has at least one or two
elements based on my life like just a
little nuggets for my life no good
tonight huh McDonald's earlier will talk
to me about then a call that you're
playing versus the Nicole that is
sitting on this couch with me okay the
Nicole M play is a little dumber than
than the clothes to be on this couch but
in the same breath that Nicole and this
couch just dumb about a bunch of other
stuff that Nicole doesn't even know
about so she's like she's gonna work
being dumb about other stuff so they
have you working every day how is that
legal well it's like five days in a row
but then I get two days off that seems
fair what does the one thing that you
want fans to know before they tune in to
the series I did this for you for you
also for me cuz I'm Lum Monning oh yeah
hey I agree yeah good for you